hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll we talk a lot about science on
this podcast and science has very lofty
goals we try to understand the
fundamental workings of nature whether
at its broadest scales its tiniest
scales or somewhere in between but
science is also part of human life which
means that there are things like
politics and human ambition that are
really tied up into the actual workings
of science another thing that is tied up
into the workings of science is money
you need money to do science whether
it's fairly inexpensive science like I
do where you need some travel money and
some graduate student support or very
very big science where you might need
literally billions of dollars to do
something like discover the Higgs boson
or detect gravitational waves so my
guest today is David Kaiser who's a
professor at MIT and a really unique
thinker in this field because he is both
a practicing physicist he's a
theoretical cosmologist like myself he
works with Alan Guth and other people at
MIT on what happened in the early
universe black holes and inflation and
stuff like that
but he's also a working historian of
science and he studies especially
physics in the 20th century which was
let's face it a go-go time for physics
not only were there great intellectual
revolutions going on but once the
Manhattan Project had come physics was
the glamour science governments could
not give enough money to physicists that
situation if you've been following along
has been changing it's becoming harder
and harder to get money for physics in
particular but arguably even for science
in general so David one of the things
that he's been thinking about these days
with a new book coming out is how money
and politics and science physics in
particular have all intersected over the
course of the 20th century it's a
fascinating story because the physics is
interesting you know what are you gonna
do when you have money what are you
gonna do when you don't have as much
money but also of course the human side
is interesting how do you make these
decisions there's essentially an
infinite number of interesting things
you could do given world enough
and time given money enough and
resources but you have to make choices
about what to do so there's just no
choice that we need to take seriously
the intersection of money politics and
science this is the podcast to go to if
you want to know how that played out in
the 20th century and what the
implications for that are going forward
I also want to mention I hope everyone
is doing well staying safe and keeping
busy during the pandemic the coronavirus
kovat 19 issue that we're all facing
worldwide as I mentioned I think before
on the podcast one of the things I'm
doing is starting a little series of
YouTube videos very informal me in front
of a camera kind of stuff right talk
about some of the great ideas in physics
and in science more broadly it is called
the biggest ideas in the universe you
can check it out the idea is that every
week I'm gonna put out a video and then
people will ask questions and the
youtube comment sections or on the blog
where I blog post it and then I will
pick out some of the best questions and
answer them in a video a couple of days
later so this is not in any sense
supposed to be a way to learn about the
virus or pandemics or anything like that
it's a way to learn about the universe
and I think that it's still important to
try to learn about the universe even
when we're trying to live in a world
that has been so dramatically changed by
this kind of event it's important as I
say elsewhere to both keep living but
also to grow and move forward this is my
way of helping us all do that I hope
everyone is doing it the best way they
can so with that let's go
[Music]
baby Kaiser welcome to mindscape podcast
thanks so much for having me good to
have you on you have this wonderfully
interdisciplinary world life role
whatever it is at MIT working physicist
writer and historian am I missing
anything
policy person well not quite policy but
I did just take on another another role
which is a bit nutty I'm now an
associate dean for social and ethical
responsibilities of computing so of
computing of computing we have a brand
new college of computing and so that's
where I mostly wear my historian of
science cap say how can we think about
science and engineering in broader
context and yeah and so that's that's
what I try to bring to that new role as
well all right so do you code very
little have you know I I I have friends
who code like the best modest yeah
nothing fancy stuff today knows me basic
quick basic yep on IBM pc's yeah I love
Mathematica shout out right in Maple I
mean that's my level anything beyond
that I yeah I need friends and students
fast so just write to the ethical
considerations I like that yeah so we're
here I think I wanted to concentrate
that the chat on science and money which
just saying the words out loud it's a
slightly ill fit right strange
bedfellows but necessary ones they're
definitely bedfellows maybe history is
the best place to start like even when
we were inventing science back in the
day in Lincoln and Galileo whatever how
did how did they get paid those
scientists they applied for grants how
did it work they didn't apply for grants
in a direct way some of them were paid
by a kind of local government and so
Galileo's first paying gigs were working
for the venetians Senate or among his
first and he was very crafty and it
could arrange his great kind of
demonstrations to get their attention
like the telescope that he did not
invent but certainly improve he
basically sold it to them as a military
a defensive device you could see the
oncoming ships quicker and I said this
is great we're give him a hundred
Scootie per year back 100 or a thousand
scooting that was when a thousand
Scootie really meant something but he
was you know who's a crafty smart guy
and so before long in fact within about
a year
les Galileo had parlayed this to a
different sort of supporter and he moved
very rapidly to be the kind of court
philosopher for the de Medicis okay and
so he moved to Florence and he was set
up as a kind of in-house researcher but
his main job was really to make the de
Medici look good it was one more kind of
bobble for court he would be his job was
to be kind of terrifically entertaining
at dinner you know like all the
physicists and stronger we know today
perfectly that mold so he was really
very expert and it turns out he was by
no means alone so Kepler was you know
Imperial mathematician for for you know
a different Emperor Emperor I guess
rudolf ii i'm sorry i don't want to i
don't gloss over too quickly the idea
that Galileo's first monetary source was
defense fund a that right in the sense
that goes back to you know
Archimedes right here the same thing
that's right now I don't want to suggest
that Galileo invented it either that's
right these are really long-standing
trends and and what we see with Galileo
and really his generation is this kind
of a variety of possibilities there is
Lauria sort of city state government
something like a local government
nations were not the big thing at the
time not in Italy in particular around a
little bit later in that century a
couple decades later nation-states did
start making formal institutions to
support research like the founding of
the Royal Society in the 1660s in
England and the French royal academies
forensic same time so there are some
kind of academies not quite universities
they're really meant to be almost more
like me like all the think tanks today
supported by the crown or by sentiments
exactly that's right
and and more often than not throughout
much of Europe it was a kind of local
Duchy or a local young noble person in
the family Tycho Brahe he an example
late example kissing up to the local
nobility yeah got a little island right
yeah I got an island with the various
observatory and lots of serfs to do a
lot of work it was really yeah and
collected a lot of data is the big data
era of astronomy was launched yeah
exactly with again with basically
private funding from a kind of local
royal so for Galileo was the switch from
sort of government money to local
nobility money intentional in the sense
that he said look I would rather be
supported in this way yes it
very much intentional he really was very
crafty so it was not only that he would
get more money which he did he would
lose his teaching obligations right the
guy was so he was teaching at the local
university and being supported by the
Venetian Senate you know in Venice or
Padua and then when he moves to Florence
his job is to think grand thoughts all
day and be very interesting at dinner I
recently visited the Galileo Museum
which by the way is not a museum about
Galileo it's the it's the Medicis Museum
and like all their baubles and he was
the greatest baubles oh he was a great
Bob still today he's the draw that's
right yeah and like I said he was maybe
the among the most kind of clever or
conniving of that cohort but he was that
was really kind of the default approach
for much of what we would now call the
Scientific Revolution right and but how
formal was it I mean how many scientists
were there asking for money that's a
really good that's a good question it's
hard it's hard to know this was just the
time when when the first things we might
recognize as learning journals were
being found it so we can go back to
libraries to particularly well-stocked
libraries today and going a page through
kind of rare books or rare journals but
even there the the the notion of a
professional scientist was not quite
what we'd recognize today that's really
a notion that emerges over the 19th
century we should say what what years
our Galileo right so Galileo's big big
breakthrough is 1609 1610 his his famous
trial with the Catholic Church is a 16
32 33 so that's back period it's a right
contemporary with Johannes Kepler
therefore a little bit later than bright
but all in that same same time period
right and I guess it's also sort of
about the same time when universities
were taking off is that fair that they
were there already
some were they're getting bigger they
were getting bigger they were also not
usually the sites for research they were
rather involved with teaching often in
many parts of Europe teaching clergy and
so they had a different role to play you
know the the oldest universities in
Europe date back to the to the 12th
century to 1100 so even you know half a
millennium before Galileo so they were
around there for a long time but they
were not sort of where seem to be where
it was that I mean Galilei was eager to
get out of a university position and
become you know court full
aasif er so they were there they were
indeed growing but they they they're not
the main story for a lot of science in
that period was there any is there any
thought that either Galileo or his many
friends and enemies worried about this
situation either the defense funding or
the private funding like was there were
they already thinking about ethical
considerations or the like thank you
there's money yeah I think a lot of it
was thank you there's money and that
person over there has even more money
thank you very much so i thats my sense
of it there were wonderful sounding
charters when we get to the kind of
nation based societies like the Royal
Society or the French Royal Academy of
Sciences in Paris there are these lovely
kind of ornate charters very
aspirational it is - you know for the
betterment of humankind kind of language
but but if you go and look at what they
were mostly supporting you know it's
it's I'm not sure we see we see we see a
hodgepodge and I'm not sure that it was
affecting daily practice so much it was
a nice thing to say so I could I
certainly think of poor Descartes who
you know made his money being a tutor
for various princesses and I made up
dying of pneumonia because he had to
move to Sweden he certainly had to leave
France he was in in the Low Countries in
Holland for quite a while not sure where
he at one of dying but he had to get the
heck out you know worried but by the
time of Newton which is soon after
Galileo I mean I think of him being a
Cambridge University he was that's right
so both as a student and then where he
although I mean as you probably remember
Sean he got most of his kind of most
world-changing work done away from
campus when the campus was closed
because the plague is true so I always
told my own MIT students you'll do much
better on spring break or you know over
the summer don't listen to me as long as
your Isaac Newton as long as long as
we're not fighting the play again as
long as Isaac Newton to ingredients but
you're right so then i noot indid make
much of his career as a professor at
Cambridge teaching mathematics or kind
of applied mathematics although even
later in his own life again as you know
he left that and became a master of the
mint he was overseeing England's
printing of money coins mostly and he
delighted in prosecuting alleged
counterfeiters and cutting off fingers
and he he had a nasty street as a
terrible person but history but also not
doing that much research by that time
at least not doing physics research he
was definitely doing biblical reason
losing a lot of public or research
throughout and also alchemical research
even experimental things and that was
continuing through much of the period
although he did work on his optics his
sort of second major famous work of
science I think is from that later
period in his career okay might have
overlapped a bit more and you know being
a physicist rather than a historian my
history tends to skip over the entire
18th century right right but one thinks
of Benjamin Franklin people like that
again not university-affiliated
no that's right and to my mind for our
beloved field showing a lot of the work
that we would look back to was being
done in the 18th century the 1700s a lot
of it in France and a lot of those folks
were kind of associated or supported by
the Royal Academy we're look at some of
them were based at universities but a
lot of them had kind of basically kind
of stipends to do interesting work and
every now and then they would compete
for large prize essay contests and
that's where a lot of the work that we
would just take for granted today by
Lagrange's pipe a song by names that we
know from our physics textbooks that's
really the the cohort who who kind of
nurtured and expanded the Newtonian
framework and you know just so much
beyond what Newton himself had ever
lived to see I love the idea of essay
contests as a way to make a living and
it continued on right plunker a very
famously you know discovered chaos
theory roughly speaking by his essay
that's right look even some of Stephen
Hawking's most important work was
submitted first as essays to the gravity
Research Foundation as a contest that
continues to this day done that I think
I think I won second place in that one
one year yeah good company Hawking do
not always win you know like an
honorable mention yeah I mean has to be
pretty sad I say not to get honorable
mention I think that there are some
pretty sad essays enter it right but uh
okay so is this taxpayer dollars in some
sense that are funding the academies so
to speak they're certainly coming from
the Royal budgets which themselves are
coming from all kinds of collections you
know new taxes and tariffs on the people
so in that sense they are state-funded
kind of by the crown when there still
were crowns but it was yeah it was
coming from the kind of let's say the
central central you know bank account
it was in that sense it was it was a it
was being funded for Dom
not by local industries not pronouncing
and not by student fees by tuition yeah
it really is predominantly kind of
national level government expenditure by
that point and I guess I should ask like
did these people think of themselves as
scientists as physicists like some
people follow themselves as
mathematicians you right now call them
physicists that's right so the the
catch-all term most of them would have
recognized would be natural philosopher
I love the sound of that still true it's
still true still great and so it's again
good to remember that although the word
science was in the English language for
a long long time the word scientist was
invented was actually introduced into
language in the 1830s well after this
period even of the laplace's of
Lagrange's let alone Newton Galileo so
there were words like astronomer there
were words like he was a natural
philosopher and mathematician and so one
of the things that Galileo in fact
wanted to do was shed the low that the
lower status title of mathematician he
was in math he was basically a
mathematics professor supported in part
by the Venetian Senate but he became a
philosopher that was so much more
special to him and to his generations
were the days those the day so he moved
from low level mathematics lowly
mathematics to being an actual court
philosopher Wow
and then okay so we're I really do want
to get to the 20th and 21st centuries so
we're skipping quickly but 1800s I'm
thinking of people like Maxwell and
Boltzmann and again some mixture of
universities and big research centers
the Prussian Academy that's right and so
the 19th century is really is sort of
time of really vast rent transformation
in in the role of what we would actually
call scientists that word itself starts
being used in English a the
institutional setting the role that
people are kind of hired in to do it's
no longer a kind of gentlemanly pursuit
now there really is a profession you can
go to school get trained and get a job
as something called a science you can
tell your parents you want to grow up to
be a scientist and be the wrong kind of
doctor that's right so that really is a
story of the kind of transformation over
the 19th century so people like Maxwell
were based at a university for much he
was at Cambridge from nearly much of his
career and he starts in fact innovating
even within their institutionally he's
becomes the founding director of the new
Cavendish laboratory so
it's amazing that he was this
mathematical physicist who handed us you
know so much of the kind of basic
theoretical physics we use day in and
day out and he be and his big promotion
was to become an experimental physicist
that had a lab yeah that's right of
course the Cavendish is still one of the
world's best labs that's right and that
was part of a move by again a kind of
national government as well as the local
university but it was part of a move
toward a kind of intentional investment
in science and engineering research for
kind of national betterment often tied
in that period to kind of imperial
ambitions will have better Telegraph's
will have better you know ships at sea
will conquer navigation so some kind of
applied projects in science and
technology for kind of nation-state
betterment or defense but not not always
limited narrowly to that and something
was it there was room for you know
investigations that were not tied
narrowly to a project but the point is
that national governments now not just
individual monarchs or kind of you know
aristocrats but actually kind of
national governments with with a more
articulated set of institutions they
began supporting what we now would
recognize as scientific research was it
always true even back to Galileo that to
these since there were nation-states or
at least local city-states people
appreciated that science was helpful the
weather united call it science natural
philosophy was helpful to national
greatness or was that a late comer on
the scene oh there there were it was
certainly a useful talking point but
what what was a measure of national
greatness one of the best things that
Kepler kept doing to keep his job was
casting really good horoscopes he was a
terrific astronomer and what the court
wanted among other things was advice on
you know national affairs we better
consult the Stars
who's our astrologer sorry so they were
they were considered useful but not
always in ways we might that we might
expect no one is a bigger believer than
I am and the importance of always
keeping learning being exposed to new
ideas making your mind expand and the
great courses plus is a great service
that helps you do this it's a streaming
service that brings to you college-level
lectures from some of the best
professors thinkers and lecturers out
there in the world from the top
universities from national
graphic Smithsonian and so forth it's
college-level learning without student
loans homework grades and all that stuff
and the great courses Plus app makes it
possible to learn whichever way works
best for you you can watch or listen to
lectures at any time so one course that
I really like is called black hole's
tides and curved space-time
understanding gravity by Benjamin
Schumacher it's a thorough introduction
to the mysteries of gravity from
Newtonian gravity to curved space-time
to gravitational waves and so much more
right now mindscape listeners get a
wonderful offer of a free trial and only
$10 a month once you sign up for a
quarterly plan so you can get the
details at the great courses plus comm
slash mindscape that's th e great
courses PLU s calm slash mindscape okay
and so we we move up to the 20th century
said okay yeah let's take a little bit
of a detour I won't talk about Einstein
in a little bit now obviously he was
pretty good he was he wasn't in the
popular press labeled a physicist I
think that he was often called a
mathematician that's right yeah there
was a continuing kind of both labels
would be used for a long time but also
he famously bounced around jobs this is
right and do we want to talk about the
extent to which that was because you
know his ideas were so radical that
people couldn't take him or just you
know sometimes it's tough to find a job
and everyone knew he was brilliant I
think it's closer to the latter but even
there we have to add upend an asterisk
that not everyone knew he was brilliant
in those early years in fact he'd made
an awful lot of powerful enemies or at
least people who were pretty annoyed he
rubbed people the wrong way he rubbed
people wrong way he was awfully arrogant
as a young man as was Galileo in fact
and that they share anything yeah
and he was quick to let professors know
that not only he thought their courses
were boring so he just wouldn't ever
show up they were hopelessly out of date
and doing unimportant things yeah and
it's one thing to think that as I'm sure
many of my own students probably still
do about me but you know thankfully they
don't tell me that to my face thanks I
had no such you know problems just
saying hey you know presser weber this
is just a waste of time
see ya and he might have been right and
he might not have been wrong every time
but he said although of course as you as
you know sometimes it came
to bite him so he cut his math classes
and then 10 to 12 15 years later comes
crawling back to his friends but would
taken the classes whose notes he had
borrowed and said oh gosh it turns out
John she's really important money and
stuff and I know it that's right so so
even there you know sometimes came back
to bite him and but again mostly his
career was spent in universities one way
or the other
not right away but he gets even actually
I'm not sure that's true he's for his
first job paying gig out of his
university studies is as a patent clerk
he was hired as a patent clerk third
class as I always say there was no
fourth class entry-level job he got it
not based on any merits because the
father was one of his close buddies
pulled some strings and even for
Einstein it wasn't what you know it's
who you know it's very sobering he dives
into the work as far as we can tell he's
seen you know he'd been fascinated by
kind of electric gadgets as a kid this
is the age of electrification he
famously recalls when an uncle gives him
a compass when he's really young this is
just mind-boggling
so he and his both his father and his
uncle were were early kind of electrical
engineers who kept failing at business
or they seemed to be pretty good as
engineers so Einstein I don't think he
necessarily saw this as a as a bad place
to start I think he loved kind of these
gadgets he worked closely with
experimentalists in many parts of his
career and tinkered with apparatus so he
starts there and Peter Galison makes the
point pretty persuasively with his work
with clocks later came important exactly
with with the real machinery of
coordinating clocks across a distance
that's right exactly
tomorrow I love that book the Peter room
so he's immersed in this kind of electro
technical kind of modern era as a as a
you know patent inspector he publishes
these basically he submits these four
articles in only the space of six months
of 1905 we call 9:25 his miracle year it
was a miracle season the guy took a half
a year likewise Newton right didn't he
like invent all of classical mechanics
over that yeah great when they were at
the play that yeah he was awfully quick
that's right but unlike Einstein Newton
sat on it for decades so that had to be
you know pulled from him from these sort
of unpublished notes
I was publishing these things so we know
we can date them and so on we know when
they were received at the journal by and
large but um so he so these things come
out of 1905 and the response from his
employer is not even to promote him he
doesn't even get voted to patent clerk
second-class no one's reading most of
these articles for years so his first
academic gig is basically about four
years later it's a entry-level position
at a kind of out of the way University
fuse later he's poached somewhere else
at him marginally less out-of-the-way
University he moves around three or four
times in the space of five years and
then in spring of 1914 so sorry both
because he he was gaming more renowned
and also he was a climber he wanted to
be at these bigger players exactly right
now that and that that much we that's
that's a great point shot we have housed
indeed at Caltech this amazing
international effort to to publish and
edit
Einstein's collected papers his
correspondence both incoming and
outgoing it's an amazing team led by it
just a terrific historian Diana
Buckwald core most and so we can we can
watch thanks to that groups help you
know this day-by-day kind of you know
grappling with hard ideas dealing with a
marriage that souring very tragically
and then also indeed a kind of social
academic climber to be sure so we have
that going on over the course of you not
quite a decade he's sort of in the
Patent Office really unknown and nine
years later he gets the call the call is
not to do more teaching that calls not
to a university post its instead to
become a member of the Prussian Academy
of Sciences where he doesn't have to
teach and he gets you know resources to
to conduct research and his job is to is
to think and when he leaves that when he
basically refuses to return to Germany
after Hitler takes power some years
later in 1933 Einstein hops ship to the
Institute for Advanced Study in
Princeton which is also not a university
where again he doesn't technically
thought a university that's true classes
no its affiliated with with Princeton
University but he was not you know
grading students papers late into the
night he was he wasn't for helped I
tried very hard to get him and how much
of that story you know
oh he loved Los Angeles and Hollywood he
loved hobnobbing with the Stars and what
I'm told I'm not sure how much on the
record or verifiable this is that the
final straw was just that Celtx
president was so anti-semitic Einstein
couldn't put up with it and he
complained about anti-semitism at
Princeton right but Caltech was just too
much yeah and and unfortunately again as
we now know Caltech was more in the in
the mainstream of American universities
elite universities than the exception at
that point so another a similar example
from right around that time for the late
1920s when J robert Oppenheimer was
first hitting the academic market very
young he skipped grades in high school
graduated Harvard three years he was
taking PhD level courses in physics his
first year as an undergraduate he's one
of those people
zooms off to Europe for his PhD and is
immediately sent a quick postdoc I
snatched up by both Berkeley and Caltech
for tenure-track Kurt is effectively
almost tenured positions and the
berkeley department chair had to fight
to get him a point because they already
had one jew on the faculty 29 that's
right and so they make an exception for
this you know indeed exceptional person
but the point is that the the
anti-semitism in hiring an indeed in
student admissions was was pretty
rampant across the united states hardly
unique to Caltech them but it did indeed
affect some of Einstein's own you know
positive opportunities so through it at
what point in this process does the idea
of applying for grants appears yeah is
that something that is coming on the
scene not in the way we'd recognize it
know a lot of this research was being
neatly should explain to the audience
who are not all professional physicists
what it means to apply for grant not
everyone knows about that well spend our
time yeah so it really in in recent
years and indeed in recent decades the
way the the vast majority of scientific
research is supported in the united
states but now really commonly in many
many parts of the world is that
researchers will submit a grant proposal
i will i will propose to do the
following investigations here's why i
think they are important here's what i
expect to be able to find only this much
time and this much money over that time
and you submit that to a variety of
kinds of recipients either a federal
agency in the united states the National
Science Foundation Department of Energy
NASA
National Institutes of Health and so on
or increasingly maybe we can come back
to an in this conversation increasingly
to private foundations or on some
occasions to individual private donors
of usually it's or indeed to to a
private industry or corporation or a
kind of industrial laboratory so you
have you say uh if you can give me this
money I can do this work on this project
not not so speak for you but I I pledge
to do this project as best I can over
these years you mean national greatness
will be enhanced and and then I'll come
back with hat in hand you know really
soon and so that's a contract basis
meaning University if so for university
based researchers like you and me
the our home universities will on our
behalf in the formal contractual sense
we submit proposal to our local
university their main office checks it
over okay it looks right then they will
submit it for example to the National
Science Foundation there'll be a whole
panel of peer review and priorities will
be hashed out congratulations MIT we
will now fund this proposal from
researcher you know x13 to nine yeah
whenever my code might be that's not my
god but anyway start from your local you
researcher and then the money will be
transferred to the University and then
eventually you know I could spend it to
hire a student or or some modest
equipment so so it's it's it's built on
the model of kind of co-equal business
partners it's not a charity it's not
cast as a charities not a gift right
which is different from before from your
longer go in history it is we have two
autonomous agents and it's very
formalized it's very legalistic
extremely formalized that's exactly
right and not just in the accounting but
in the language what's allowed by this
agreement it is it's a legal contract
and with all the headaches that that
might employ just to illustrate you know
you can you can travel to a conference
and pay for your hotel using a grant
money but there is a limit on how many
dollars per night you can spend that's
right now and don't charge you know
alcohol to it I'm just perfectly
appropriate not to do things like the
limits than what it can be spent on and
how much per category and that has me
really spelled out and often if you want
to change the allotments oh I need to
make another trip to Vienna to meet with
Mike
colleagues but I only budgeted this much
for international travel and you know
it's a it's a negotiation so so that's
the current process and it really was
put in place not in Galileo's day not
even in Einstein's day that emerges from
the second world war it's pretty recent
in history and it was engineered
literally engineered by an MIT
researcher and kind of administrator
named vetiver Bush he had been dean of
engineering here he helped found
Raytheon Corporation in the 1930s he was
basically an electrical engineer and he
his real brilliance was really in
administration so he was tapped by
Franklin Roosevelt even before the
United States and formally entered the
Second World War
Bush became the person in charge on how
to organize science and engineering for
for defense for the nation's sort of
clearly soon to be you know defense
effort even even before the surprise
attack on middle partner right yeah
there was there was a kind of
preparation going on and Bush was really
one of the chief engineer architects of
that related to our presidents Bush I
think there was no relation same same
spelling but no I don't think there's
any direct connections that I know of
and so Bush is entering like many of the
kind of elite university administrators
of that time and a lot of especially
private universities they were many of
them were were very strongly anti New
Deal they didn't think the federal
government had should be you know moving
into education now look that smelled of
like central planning so they thought
that the federal government had no
business in the job of education they
shouldn't be involved in universities so
there were failed efforts before the
Second World War for example here at MIT
in other places to actually get federal
support for research on campus and those
were just sort of fizzle out that was
not the template that was not the model
that changes very rapidly in in the
early 1940s and so Bush didn't want to
have even the appearance of a kind of
you know what would smelled to him too
much of a kind of socialism fairly or
unfairly that's what he thought this
would lead to so he said we'll have a
business contract right we'll have a
private sector model free-market kind of
model - autonomous aid
we'll enter into a binding legal
agreement the federal government needs
us we need them we two parties come to
the table we hash out a deal a contract
and that becomes the kind of grant the
basis for grant making that really ramps
up at an unbelievable rate during the
Second World War and really never slows
down or or
doesn't slow down for a long long time
for decades afterwards here in the US
and that quickly becomes kind of
exported as a model to support research
many places beyond the United States
world war two clearly changed everything
right about science and money and I
think that if you told the person on the
street that that was true they would
agree with you but they would attribute
it all to the Manhattan Project and
atomic bombs but it goes far further
than that it really doesn't and this is
a fascinating period of history and I've
written about and I am continually kind
of just amazed by it
so both the radar projects the Allied
efforts and radar very quickly were
shifted to be headquartered here at MIT
and the Manhattan Project which was much
more sprawling that will head up having
more than 30 locations across both the
United States and Canada with large
inputs from the British and Canadian
contingents so it wasn't just Los Alamos
it was three dozen sites contracting
sites some very large those were
incredibly important examples of this
new relationship between the federal
government in particularly military
those kind of War Department too because
it was then called and often university
based researchers physicists chemists
engineers of many many stripes and
metallurgists linguists social
scientists as well in some of these
projects but that that that's you're
right that's that's not even the biggest
story it by some ways to measure there
was an even more fervent effort starting
even before the Manhattan Project was
was kind of scaling up for a different
kind of partnership with with research
with science and that was to train lots
of people in rudimentary physics yeah
and I found this really fascinating for
after World War Two the phrase the
physicist war was used all the time and
people would use it to refer to radar
but especially the nuclear weapons
project to Los Alamos and the bombs and
that's how the term gets kind of
reinterpreted people would say in a very
you know reminder World War one was the
chemists war theme a poison gas doesn't
snow on World War two was the physicists
where because of these kinds of projects
they mean almost always radar in the
bomb it turns out the usage of the
phrase physicist wars we can now tell by
tools like you know google engrams we
can search huge Corp I you know
english-language text that the usage of
the word spikes while the Manhattan
Project is barely existing and still
classified while radar is slightly
bigger and still classified so the
people on the street don't know that
these things are going right these
newspaper editors are not spilling
secrets they don't even know about
they've used the term to refer as it was
used routinely in congressional
testimony and it was in the public face
a lot in the early years of World War
two but it meant this massive training
program to Train often could have
enlisted soldiers service members across
the various branches of the military in
really rudimentary physics the modern
battlefield meant you had to know
something about electronics and circuits
and radio for you know really kind of
rudimentary communication something like
sound ranging you know how to sound
waves propagate through a battlefield so
I know that the sniper shot was from
here not there so how do you measure you
know humidity and angles and and basic
atmospheric conditions so it was what we
would consider kind of really high
school level physical sciences it was
certainly not esoteric nuclear physics
that was being really rapidly sought and
this remade many many American campuses
there was a huge push to get enlisted
members onto campus for short very very
intense seven-day week many hours per
day instruction in basic physics this
was called the physicists war the first
academic specialty that we started
getting draft deferments were physicists
not so they'd make weapons so they'd
stay in the classroom people who were in
math and everything from mathematics to
music to philosophy faculty were kind of
drafted not not drafted in a formal
military sense were grabbed on so they
could also teach rudimentary physics to
these enormous auditorium fools of
enlisted you know service members so
that became the physicist war it's that
the modern battlefield needs class what
we now call classical physics and we
need you know hundreds of thousands of
people to be cognizant of these things
so that's just it remakes physics it
remakes large parts of the university
and it really solidifies this
increasingly close working relationship
between the federal government including
the War Department the military and
defense branches and you know academic
research do you know the story of the
health tech football team you can tell
me that I do Cal Tech is not you know a
sports powerhouse in the NCAA in any
stretch but if you go to the gym there's
a little plaque that put that mentions
that the 19 I don't know what it is 43
Cal Tech football team is in the
collegiate Sports Hall of Fame and
there's an explanation if you go online
the explanation is the following there
was no football at Cal Tech but during
the war people basically a whole bunch
of army soldiers who had been training
at Stanford or something like that or
moved to Cal Tech to training Cal Tech
they wanted to play football Cal Tech
didn't have a team right so that they
hurriedly put together a schedule which
consisted of two games against the
University of Redlands and one game each
against USC and UCLA JV teams right and
so these soldiers destroyed their
competitors by like in four games the
total score was like 230 to zero and the
that such such a showman show of bad
sportsmanship got them into the
n-c-double-a Hall of Fame for being one
of the best football teams of all time
well congratulations yeah that's
fantastic but that's that is and it all
adds up it's a great example of these
campuses were really overrun by at MIT
by a few years into this into this
project there were sort of three
basically you know enlisted service
members on campus for every two ordinary
students there were more people in these
special army and navy courses gasps
campus than then kind of ordinary
college students it's also why a lot of
campuses switched to a trimester or a
quarter system got a squeeze more stuff
in shorter amount of time there's a war
on money that kind of mentality so it
really hasn't and just an amazing impact
on campuses and on the structure of
American higher education
did it change the appearance of physics
in the curriculum at non Milford
non-military students oh yeah I mean it
was it was I mean the emphasis was
basically get through this again kind of
we might think of kind of high school
level stuff because half the high
schools the United States weren't
offering any physics at all a sort of
astonished officials began to to realize
so a lot of it was was pretty
rudimentary there were expert panels
advising groups like both the War
Department and the Office of Education
the Federal Office of Education during
the war panels of university based
physicists part of the American
Institute of Physics would help staff
these kind of blue-ribbon committees and
they explicitly argued that departments
should not offer useless material like
nuclear physics during the war in
hindsight because that will take too
much you know too many resources too
many classroom hours away from what what
the campus needed to fulfill there were
all these formulas that anyone who was
seen as poaching legitimate physics
instructors yeah and if you're getting a
music professor to go teach you know
Newton's mechanics you there really want
to get all hands on deck so to the
extent that university might be
jockeying to hire you know some hotshot
from another campus there would be you
know kind of you'd come in for very
strict you know get a very strict
talking to if you if you were disrupting
this emergency physics instruction so if
I graduated from a good university or
college in the 1930s is it likely that I
would never have had any physics in
either high school or university yeah if
you were not a physical sciences student
yes that's right
so there were something I came out with
the numbers exactly was something like
half the high schools or half the high
school age children of students were
getting zero physics instruction at all
okay on the eve of the war yeah that's
right and and on the other hand you have
people like Oppenheimer coming up who
had so much physics as a student that he
could jump right ahead and write in
Harvard so clearly it was unevenly
distributed as so many things remain in
education so clearly an enormous amount
of money flooded into physics during the
war right but then it didn't go away
that's right you know that's right and
so after you know the the the very
dramatic revealing of the presence of
these bombs and they were revealed in a
denim in a horribly destructive way by
using them against the Japanese cities
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki in August
early August 1945 that by that point
physics was on every
one's lips tied now to these sort of
amazing or unusual or unexpected weapons
and there's another real kind of amazing
irony of history that happens there we
now know many historians have looked in
detail at this and scientists of many
stripes what kinds of expertise did it
take to build these nuclear weapons
during the Second World War
certainly needed some physics and needed
a lot of chemistry Chemical Engineering
metallurgy electrical engineering and
the list is very long some of the most
visible experts associate with the
project were physicists Robert
Oppenheimer Hans bethe head of the
theory division at Los Alamos and so on
but a lot of it was you know incredibly
complicated work by you know DuPont
chemical engineers scaling up reactors
and making sure they would they would
produce plutonium because they've kept
not working first not so much biology
but these days there would be a lot of
much larger biological component that's
right that's right that was much less
significantly represented in in the
middle of the Second World War begin to
change after the war that's right so but
however there was an effort to control
what could be said about nuclear weapons
once they once they were used so in real
time during the war general Leslie
groves who was the army general in
charge of the entire Manhattan Project
he commissioned a physics colleague
named Henry de Wolfe Smith who was a
nuclear physicist he'd been department
head at Princeton a very elite
well-trained nuclear physicist and he he
recruited Smyth not to work as a nuclear
physicist on the bomb project but to
work as a real time reporter as a kind
of real time historian of the project he
was given the appropriate clearance and
his job was to visit many of these sites
Los Alamos Oak Ridge Hanford and many of
the even smaller sites throughout the
war to write a report on how the weapon
was designed and built that could be
cleared and and safe to release ahead of
time so that they weren't accidentally
revealing the so-called secrets of
atomic bombs the atomic secret and yet
they knew there'd be an enormous need
for information so tell a story but not
the whole story that's exactly right
that's right and so it turns out that
this is where the first nuclear based
classification codes are actually
literally
codified it's what can Smythe include in
his report even after years after the
war if it's in the smart port you can
publish it if it's not it is de facto
born classified so what do they decide
is safe enough to release in fact the
regulations even say that at the time
secret rules that govern this report the
information can only be released in the
report if it's already widely known to
professional scientists and in the
published literature or if it has no
significant bearing on the construction
of atomic weapons what meets that test a
lot of nuclear physics had very little
to do with how these things were
actually made it was either so widely
known that that it was the cat was in
the was that a bag or litter was just
not the stuff that people thought was
most needed to be kind of locked down
which really was how do you get uranium
hexafluoride is horribly corrosive gas
not to eat through your metal gaskets in
these filtration systems how do you stop
the huge reactors at Hanford from self
poisonings you can actually get
plutonium out instead of having the
reactions kind of halt how do you you
know get subcritical chunks of these
very strange materials to to get
imploded together very very you know
supersonic speeds which was not at all
obvious I struggled with that during the
war we all of these are are only barely
physics problems and those interested we
can't ever let that stuff out right so
the irony is this Meyer Thurber comes
out and it looks like physicists built
the bomb because this Martha Ford is
filled with ideas about kind of
elementary quantum physics and I should
say this is work that really would first
came to light by a terrific historian
named Rebecca press Schwartz and others
historians including myself others have
followed that trail since then so it's
it's another one he's like we all think
we know what's going on oh the physicist
war Oh
bombs were made by physicist nukes and
actually you know gosh it gets pretty
complicated and clearing in things that
they chose not to tell us how about how
did we come to tell that story is itself
part of the story but I guess it's a
little bit of a diversion from our
self-chosen theme but since we all all
of us probably listening here have all
of our lives known about nuclear weapon
right it's kind of hard to imagine what
it would have been like just not only we
have a really big bomb but we have a
really big bomb because of something
about the laws of physics
there's this new insight it wasn't just
we took the bomb that we had and made it
bigger mmm there is this way of doing
things we hadn't thought of that mud it
must have been a little scary it was
scary but I think that's right and yet
in the earliest moments in if you if we
judge by a lot of the you know popular
media coverage in newspapers and
magazines
it was often combined with the kind of
gee whiz it was wrapped around a kind of
weave the the scientists by which they
almost always bet at that point meant
the physicists have you know conquered
the forces of nature they've conquered
the reactions that drive the Sun of
course they weren't doing fusion weapons
at night but yet a few years later but
that's the language I've used it they
captured cosmic forces and now we can
make them do our bidding and that
sounded not just like physics was
relevant it seemed like physics was you
know the most important thing in
literally in the universe and that again
has this an immediate kind of unintended
effect throughout especially us-based
higher education to spillover effects we
can trace in many other parts of the
world as well so that enrollments in
physics departments grow twice at at a
rate that's twice as fast as as sort of
all fields combined it just races ahead
more and more people want to go into
physics than ever before classrooms are
bulging now not with service members who
need rudimentary physics but with very
smart people who say I'm going to work
on the forces of nature on these cosmic
mysteries and exciting projects funding
is now sort of accelerating it at a
rip-roaring pace for physics even more
than for ironically therefore some of
those other fields that we really were
so important for it for applied military
projects and so one thing I've looked at
for quite a while is the kind of growth
rates for enrollments for funding for
job opportunities but also even we step
away from the countable from our kind of
Excel spreadsheets and just think about
the kind of cultural place of the
physicists in the years right after the
Second World War one example I love
there was a private by invitation only
little meeting for roughly 20 or maybe
two dozen hands elected physicists in
1947 roughly two years after the end of
the war okay on Shelter Island off the
North Fork of Long Island this was a
meeting Sean probably close to your
hearts where people first began figuring
how to
use quantum field theories and make
calculations wouldn't always lead to
infinity mean the infinities
renormalization readily important they
the the first successful answers were
reported at the next one in that series
but in 1947 people were learning about
brand-new experiments that just seemed
so so so you had to pay attention to
them so names like Hans bethe and
Richard Feynman and Julia that's exactly
right and and Willis lamb and Isidor
Rabi presents them these newest
experimental findings that really kind
of electrify the group they're brought
together largely by Robert Oppenheimer
who by this point has left his Berkeley
position he's moved now to be director
of the Institute for Advanced Study he's
now in Stein's boss as the press would
love to say it and he can he with he
gets government money to convene this
very elite group for a kind of retreat
where they'll go think about you know
the mysteries of the quantum realm
together and how to describe matter in
this quantum mechanical way the reason I
bring this up is that they they met at
this sort of American Institute of
Physics headquarters in Manhattan which
is at the time in Manhattan to take a
kind of rickety school bus off to Long
Island and midway along their journey
they could pick up a police escort
because someone says hey there's a bunch
of physicists in that van those are the
ones who won the war forth that's why
you know such-and-such didn't have to we
didn't the u.s. didn't have to mount a
land invasion of Japan and all these
kinds of stories that were circulating
those are physicists another booster a
kind of recent veteran along the way
stops the bus and insists on buying a
steak dinner for all those that's what
starts to happen is another physicist
kind of bemused or surprised physicist
around that same time who writes that
that you know every dinner party it
needs physicists they're paraded around
sort of the women's you know luncheon
groups in Washington DC among the
socialites even people had no role in
the wartime projects that though the the
the job description of physicists
suddenly meant something very different
than it ever had before and as I always
remind my students my favorite example
comes from Harper's Magazine in the late
40s where an observer writes that no
dinner party is a success without at
least one physicist we can all agree on
that
I said we're finally discovered that
fact yeah and and yet and they look at
us now I still thought invited
that's right but that's the moment of
that can be a cultural shift I mean one
of the interesting features of this is
physicists did play a very big role in
the combat operations in World War two
and the technology behind them that gave
them access afterward for decades
afterward to a whole bunch of money but
the money wasn't narrowly focused on
military applications those people in
the bus going to Shelter Island right
normalizing quantum electrodynamics
there were zero applications for that
certainly none that they had in mind at
the time absolutely right and that's
another thing that I found really
curious on a dug in and was doing some
more similar sort of investigating
wearing my historians cap so there the
the overarching kind of policy that took
form very rapidly in this in this kind
of chaotic post-world War two period was
that we need to keep funding basic
research in in the sciences and by which
that they by which they almost always
meant physics more than any others
rightly our unerring directly fairly
unfairly they science often meant
physics to these folks really quick
slippage we need them not because
they'll make better widgets or gadgets
or military devices but so they'll be on
call we want to make what they
themselves would often call a standing
army we want to have the world's
greatest pool of talent we want to make
sure that they are technically
proficient they have the best equipment
in the universe to to kind of hone their
skills on even if they're not using that
equipment right here and now to make
better you know can military
applications so that if the Cold War
turns hot if a new outright phase of
fighting World War two to to break out
they wouldn't spend all that time
staffing up the next Manhattan Project
not only would they be there they would
the US government would know who they
were where they were they'd already be
paying them they'd really be on the
payroll efforts to make a natural
national registry of physicists could
kick in in this point not sort of for
surveillance purposes but to say we need
to know where our technical experts are
if and when we need them and that
prevails for nearly a quarter century
that assumption leads to an enormous
enormous kind of rocketing forward
amount of funding and enrollments follow
suit and job opportunities grow even
faster and well you use the phrase cold
war that's the point right World War
but the cold the fact that there was
still the cold war going on and it was
clearly this technological race made
explicit in the space race but a much
broader one right that absolutely fed
into the idea that we need to keep
throwing money at physics absolutely and
remember even long before Sputnik or the
space race you know a lot of people were
very concerned about about the
proliferation of nuclear weapons as many
people are even to this day but at that
point year the United States had a
monopoly even that statements not quite
right the the Manhattan Project had been
a three country partnership in the
United States Britain and Canada it one
would have thought had a man I'd a
triple Appa Lee whatever although very
rapidly relations soured even there so
became really a u.s. project and
relations were strained nonetheless no
other nation state literally possessed
these things after the war and all the
projections seem to suggest that the
Soviet Union which was rapidly emerging
as the kind of presumptive rival or
enemy as the Cold War really set in they
many many policymakers in the United
States convinced themselves those
there's such a backward people they're
kind of failing even at agriculture this
horrible disasters of collective farming
there are kind of backward rural people
not able to do this with a gleaming high
tech Science and Technology and of
course that was really you know proven
to be untrue within basically four years
so by the the by late August 1949 the
Soviets had detonated their own atomic
weapon with a with some kind of
complicated role played by espionage but
a lot of it was we again historians and
scientists got back over these things
once many documents became available
after the fall of Union it's not that
this was a kind of carbon copy of the
American bomb there's there was a lot of
hard work major expenditures trial and
error nonetheless this group of highly
trained experts in the Soviet Union
produced what the United States was
confident would would only ever be in
the United States and then that triggers
this arms race soon you need it was felt
that one that each country needed not
just more weapons weapons of greater
explosive power and then of course too
a whole different means of making
nuclear reactions release lots of energy
meaning switching from fission bombs of
the sort that have been used and evolved
during the war to fusion bombs that
really do harness reactions more like
what go on this lesson yeah and that is
just you know I just kind of drumbeat
kind of terrifying drumbeat of activity
from the late 40s right through really
much of the 1950s even before Sputnik
and space racin and rockets and you know
scientists are always happy to take the
money if it's gonna be out there but
there must have been some awkward
rubbing of shoulders just because the
culture of academia and intellectual
freedom of speech free trade free
exchange of ideas is a little bit
different than a more closed-minded
secretive military mindset right that's
right and that was it was a kind of
culture clash from from the earliest
days of of the Manhattan Project of
Alice Ellis in particular and this was
again famously kind of fought out duped
out by robert Oppenheimer who was the
physicist and was the scientific
director of wartime Los Alamos who had
to work very closely with Leslie groves
the in the Army General who was really
in charge of the whole project groves a
favored policy a very strict
compartmentalization so you want you to
only ever have access to the information
that you genuinely need for your own
part of this large project you
compartmentalize the knowledge so no
individual has access to too many things
and we seen that would seem to be
dangerous and that clearly method was
therefore you know huge kind of
restrictions on communication even among
fellow scientific experts on the same
project let alone in the larger
community
Oppenheimer won a kind of early battle
with groves by getting groves to agree
that people with the right kind of
seniority the right kind of literally
colored badge a wartime Los Alamos could
attend a colloquium together in in how
still kind of classified open only to
those that rather modest group so at
least they could brainstorm and kind of
problem shoot things together you know
in and not only be separated into
separate compartments even that was kind
of a hard-fought battle that one
Oppenheimer tremendous you know
accolades from his fellow scientists on
the
Mesa and groves gave in a little bit but
that was really inside that did not
become the model for the project or
indeed for much work they would go on in
the years to come so that one of the
great concerns that starts unfolding at
places like MIT and many many
universities after World War two is not
only is a so much this research being
funded by the military branches
defense-related branches of the federal
government sometimes students are
writing theses based on classified
information so you know who could even
serve on a student's committee is
suddenly not so straightforward
could the University Library you know
stock a copy of the thesis that's that's
that's a big question right for
University and so there was a real a
period of real we could say transition
but it was a kind of live issue was
fraught for one or two generations and
it really comes to a head in the later
1960s so you know 20 years later it
people fight over it never quite gets
resolved until the escalation of
fighting in the Vietnam War and that
leads to just a tremendous kind of
rethink of the military role in u.s.
higher education after the 60s you find
many many many universities adopting
some some of them for the first time
policies that say we will accept Defense
Department dollars but under these
conditions students must be able to
publish their work you know the
renegotiation of secrecy information
sharing you know freedom of expression
still one of the money yes
unfortunate was the same time when a lot
of that money was beginning to dry up
well that's also true
people are still surprised when I
sometimes tell them that through my life
is a working physicist much of my grant
money has been from the Department of
Energy mm-hmm right because they think
well this isn't that like oil and
nuclear power and I I don't understand
what you do for a living but it's not
that right this is part of that
historical development right yes is the
National Science Foundation but that's
actually not what funds most of high
energy physics including string theory
or technology yep yep yep let alone big
instruments I mean like huge equipment
but even people like you and me who work
mostly with pencils and some odd
computer work like we were saying before
right so the Department of Energy
historically is the kind of third wave
successor to the Manhattan Project and
of course it's change it's not doesn't
have the same you know kind of job
description as it once did but the order
of events is basically the Manhattan
Project is founded in the early 1940s is
established in the early 1940s in secret
at first soon after the end of the war
starting officially in 1946 there is the
establishment of a civilian agency a
nominally civilian agency called the
Atomic Energy Commission of the AEC
that's meant to take over the wartime
Manhattan Project is it's it was a big
fight should have continued being a
military project or a civilian one and
the basically the kind of compromise was
it would be a civilian one with very
heavy input from the military I mean
more than just kind of liaison but so
nominally the war departments and
Manhattan Project becomes a civilian
federal agency called the Atomic Energy
Commission then basically in the early
1970s that's briefly renamed era I think
that was in the energy research and
development agency and then quickly it's
renamed yet again the Department of
Energy so we really can trace an
unbroken line between the wartime
Manhattan Project in the do-e now the
again the the role of the DOA the
Department Energy has continued to
expand and more if it's not just the
wartime at hand right by any stretch but
nonetheless it inherits that legacy and
so that includes a lot of the work at
National Laboratories some of it now
explicitly for you know a defense
research and a lot of it now for
unclassified open-ended kind of basic
research but all good things come to an
end there was you know not only
individual grants were booming in this
era but it was a period tremendous
discovery in fundamental physics yes
articles were popping up all the time
right and so starting in 70s 80s 90s
both the Cold War lines down and the
discoveries dry up so what hasn't well a
lot of things happen so the Cold War in
hindsight we know didn't quite end in
1970 but it sure looked like it might
yeah there was a moment of what came to
be called day Todd I kind of you know
ratcheting back at least of some of the
kind of rhetoric and real it felt like a
hair-trigger kind of tension and there
was a moment of a kind of reset in
us-soviet relations as we know that then
ratchets back up into a more hostile or
antagonistic framework even by the early
mid 1980s but there was a moment it was
a moment in the seventies there where
different priorities started to take
hold at a kind of national policymaking
level and that coincided with some a
real economic downturn so that's a
period of what is often called
stagflation so you have stagnant growth
and rising unemployment together with
with rising inflation so the given a
dollar would buy you less and less over
time and economists didn't think those
two things would go together yeah people
thought you either had unemployment or
inflation right so this was a new or at
least an unanticipated phenomenon and it
really settled in hard and it was a very
very dismal time economically and that
what that meant was universities and a
special university based physicists were
hit with a double whammy starting in the
early 1970s there's major cutbacks in
defense spending part of it because of
policy shifts the kind of the Cold War
priorities are now being reevaluated and
combined with huge cutbacks and spend in
federal funding for education partly
because the economy's just not doing
well then there's the oil shocks I mean
just it's a tremendously disrupting time
in the US and many parts of the world
economically seventies were kind of a
drag 70s anyway I mean it was just not
more of the same people were flocking to
universities before then often flocking
still to fields like physics and then a
lot of them got there and felt a bit
like the other rugged and pulled out in
the decade after the launch of Sputnik
so between the late 50s and late 60s the
number of departments had offered PhDs
in physics had doubled in the United
States it really was still a growth
phase we need more more more more more
and then we have this enormous glut in
the country and the bottom falls out so
much so that by 1968 there are many more
young PhDs in physics seeking jobs than
there are jobs you know available or at
least advertised and then by 1971 the
bottom is just
the American Institute is xscape
statistic they ran a Cana Clearinghouse
to match up your young physicists
applying for jobs and potential
employers and buy their own records by
1971 they were more than 1,000 young PA
cheese registered for interviews who
wanted interviews and 53 jobs on offer
that wasn't 53 university jobs that
included jobs at government labs
industrial labs they all kind of
cratered together largely because more
than any other field in the academy
physics had gotten sort of hooked on a
single source of support in the quarter
century after the Second World War
things had worked with the AEC or its
close partners in the federal government
and when federal funding you know kind
of shook when it went when that pattern
became disrupted your physics had
nowhere to go but down chemists had a
century of experience partnering with
industries and so on they were their
funding went down their student Romans
went down but nothing is kind of
cataclysmic they were diversified they
were diversified biologists certain some
of them are just beginning what will
become an exciting trend of
biotechnology again it kind of we might
say a diversified portfolio and to speak
a bit anachronistically they were there
were varieties of ways of supporting
very expensive research in other fields
and physics had just kind of never moved
out of that kind of single source model
so so physics enrollments had grown
faster than any of the field after World
War two they crash more quickly more
dramatically than any other field in the
early 70s he's really good just
breathtakingly symmetrical but then the
economy picked up in the 1980s and yet
physics still began to feel the squeeze
a little bit there's I know that you
know you and I were both around in our
formative years right superconducting
supercollider that's behind of disaster
is that an omen you think oh yeah yeah
maybe tell people it was I will so the
superconducting supercollider was a an
enormous particle accelerator that was
under construction it was proposed and
actually the funding was approved by the
US Congress in the mid 1980s under the
Reagan administration it was going to be
the design specs were that it would be
not only the largest of his kind but
would have dwarfed even the best
machines on earth to this day and this
was being proposed you know 30 years
more than 30 years ago it was a terrific
ambitious project the SSC would have
been much higher energy than the Large
Hadron Collider which were also proud of
right exactly what's covered the hague
by if it ever met its design specs by
like a factor of three it really would
be substantially more and higher
energies and also more intensity more so
interactions per fraction of a second
and this was seen as a great kind of
more than a lifeline this is named as
the future of the field exactly the time
when you and I were young students and
what happened was the the the project
kept getting more and more expensive
exceeding even the earlier cost
estimates and much more important the
Cold War ended the Soviet Union is off
the Berlin wall comes down in 1989 the
Soviet Union itself dissolves quite
surprisingly or unexpectedly for many
observers in the United States that
dissolves a night in 1991 and suddenly
the kind of self-evident reason to spend
money on esoteric unapplied in
fundamental physics like what how like
is there a Higgs boson or what are the
fundamental forces of nature the reason
to do that no longer see is supportable
or supported by you know a majority of
members of Congress which is weird
because it was never the right reason to
do it it's right you know I was talking
about this recently with some colleagues
in Europe and they were like why in the
world did the Cold War have anything in
it and it's such a US focus it was for
music how would you not know oh right so
it really goes back to a tradition that
stems right back to the immediate
aftermath of the Second World War
early in the in the 40s and 50s the
federal government would fund duplicate
machines the sort of SSC's of their day
they weren't as radically expensive but
there were big expensive infrastructure
projects to make these particle
accelerators their own scientific
advisory board would say we only need
one key to and they say oh but we'll
keep morale high the word they use was
morale of the nation's physicists and
make sure we can train that many more
graduate students those two flakes they
are yes exactly that's right so the the
federal government paid for more stuff
than even the physicists sometimes asked
sometimes asked for in the late 40s
early 50s when when the u.s. entered the
Korean War in 1950 the response was will
make more graduate fellowships for for
students in physics
the Atomic Energy Commission made a
calculation in 1951 while the u.s. is at
war in the Korean Conflict saying if
this is a near quotation from their
memos from memory but it's pretty close
they say if an nuclear physicists are
willing and able to use a particle
accelerator and if a reasonable team is
sort of you know five people per machine
we'll just build that the appropriately
and over five until the war ends right
not until they learn more about
deuterons right until the that way this
was seen as not making weapons it was
seen as aiding this training mission
well that's the argument that no longer
holds any water yeah by the time the
SSC's number comes up here Shawn you we
were both in Cambridge Massachusetts
around that time I think we were so when
the final vote in Congress to kill the
the the funding came up it was October
1993 I remember that because I entered
grad school to study high-energy physics
in September of 1993 so I don't think it
was personal slight on that behalf but
it really was no planning perhaps if
only I'd known then what I know now and
so it really was as dramatic dislocation
in fact that one vote to cancel funding
for this multi-billion dollar project to
vote in 1993 meant that in one year the
federal budget for the entire field of
high-energy physics fell in half yeah no
I was just beginning my postdoc here at
MIT that year and we physicists in the
Boston area had a town hall meeting
where it was mostly therapeutic
screaming not a lot of good planning
like what are we gonna do yep-yep-yep
and it was it was in again with
hindsight it was a remarkable replay of
what had already happened in our own you
know in our in our teachers own memory
right and in the generation older than
us because this is a remarkably similar
to what happened in the early 70s this
enormous cratering where the the
projections had been we need more and
more physicists to the unlimited funding
and unlimited jobs and of course that's
not sustainable it crashed seemingly all
of a sudden around 1970 71 it crashed
seemingly all of a sudden in the early
90s Europe did manage to build Large
Hadron Collider and the United States
sort of sheepishly bought in right and
gave some money as a junior partner in
science but these days the United States
has more
it's not even trying to build the next
great particle accelerator you know
Europe and China are vying for the
rights and that's probably what this
could be like for the foreseeable future
if anyone else can even can even do it
that's right it certainly won't be in
the United States I think that much we
can bet on with some certainty now there
were it's it's it's really curious at
that just a year before the SSC was
cancelled the the federal government now
a different branch the National Science
Foundation rather than the Department of
Energy the NSF in 1992 began pretty
substantial funding for what would
become like Oh a major infrastructure
project required major in residential
laser interferometric gravitational wave
Observatory LIGO which sort of paid off
scientifically decades later
I mean thrillingly right thank goodness
but think about a quarter century of
foresight to say we will invest you know
civilian tax dollars at the roughly
billion dollar level in something just
by the way will never result in a
gravity wave bomb it will not erode
although I have to say many of my very
dear friends and colleagues have worked
on that for most of their careers here
at MIT right we're done gravitational
waves not gravitational wave bomb I'm
sorry I should thank you for correcting
I mean to say gravitational waves of the
of the amazingly fascinating and
non-destructive sort place right so
gravity waves and in the 80s when people
before the funding came through in any
sustained way some people would say you
know they would add sentences because
it's almost out of habit I assume to
their grant proposal saying by the way
along the way we might find you know
lessons of possible military relevance
they didn't mean the gravitational waves
would weaponize they meant we'll be
learning more about electronics could be
hearings and lasers there could be
spin-offs along the way even if that was
by no means the reason to do it so
that's a marker again of sort of how did
one justify spending for even open-ended
basic research there was a kind of
template in the u.s. that was frankly
just never what took hold after the
Second World War for all kinds of
reasons that's not the CERN model it
hasn't been CERN was meant to be instead
something to kind of heal the waters of
the European nuclear physics
for the center that's now based in
Geneva but multinational from the start
and who was from very early on bringing
together representatives from countries
that did not otherwise always you know
we're not always close allies and had to
have a very bright red line demarcating
anything could possibly be construed as
military relevance from this
multinational basic science laboratory
so the CERN model was never hooked up in
quite the same way to kind of Cold War
politics of priorities and the US model
had been remarkably effective with some
waves I mean not not not in an unbroken
way but over over the better part of
half a century and that number you know
came up right and and part of this the
narrative around this is that the 20th
century was the century of physics and
the 21st century is a century of biology
and biology is not only you know
visceral and we all have it yes not all
of us think about physics but we all
think about biology yeah every year a
little bit more right but also the
individual biology projects are
generally much cheaper than the
individual big physics projects by even
the biggest big biology project some of
which should get big the Human Genome
Project was hardly an inexpensive
project but when you look at just sort
of you know baseline appropriations they
they were not the same is that one of
the things that the physicists began to
learn to a little bit late its kind of
to two there or or our chagrin is that
by the time we got to the projects like
the superconducting supercollider with
an eight billion price tag then whereas
maybe would rise even to 15 billion it
wasn't so clear that's that's now
competing with you know the kinds of
budget items that make members of
Congress really notice it's not rounding
error it's not hidden in some boring
document from some unimportant agency
right that's you know if you adjust for
inflation if you're just for the buying
power of a US dollar yeah it's like ten
times more expensive than the Hoover Dam
yeah right it's now approaching the cost
of things like designing and building
the b-29 you know aircraft in the Second
World War
it's now it's an ax level of major
military projects of major sort of civil
society projects of infrastructure
that then you know becomes a big target
for people to to to look at more
skeptically maybe appropriately so but
that's what it's scaled up and I think a
lot of people in the physics profession
didn't quite realize the shift of what
it would mean to be arguing in what was
no longer blank check era for that kind
of price tag projects it just everyone
in Congress loved the SSC until they
decided where they were going to put it
that's right
and there was definitely it was not
going to pay off in 50 you know States
or many districts but one site selection
was completed that's right but even but
even beyond that the arguments that were
locked in a existential battle with the
Soviets well there's no way right we
need you know at all cost we need super
smart trained you know physical
scientists because well because why
right and so the kinds of argument that
had worked really over and over again
for generations they the argument didn't
make sense and the price tag was so much
larger than before that just it just
wasn't gonna it just crashed and
something just a science point worth
making here is it's not just that we
like building bigger and bigger
accelerators there's certain kinds of
science that can only be done that way
right so it's not a matter of if you pay
half the money for the accelerator you
get half the size oh that's your pay
half the money for these other we get
nothing right and so the question is and
it's a perfectly good question is it
worth doing this kind of science at all
right that's the entry fee yeah it is a
good question it's a question that that
physicists need to grapple with and of
course many many people beyond physics
no longer you know only up to us and
that was again made quite dramatically
clear so what one thing that happens is
there are these massive disruptions like
the cancellation of the SSC they can
have unintended intellectual
consequences as well as demographic ones
who goes on who gets a grant who gets
who can can get a job those are easier
to relate to these big-budget shifts
their shifts in the kind of world of
ideas as well and that really fascinates
me both you know as a physicist and an
ism historian and one of the things that
begins to happen both in the crash of
the 70s and again in the crash of the
90s crash in funding and so on is that
some very very very smart particle
physicist high-energy physicists begin
kind of shifting their their question
basically asking questions in for
example astrophysics in a way that
simply wasn't common for them to do
before the 1970s not common in the
United States or to biophysics or to to
other kind of hybrid areas or condensed
matter theory one of the very first
mindscape guests was Jeffrey West who
very famously like literally because the
SSC was cancelled said I'm not doing
this anymore he had been a particle
physicist he became a complexity
theorist and actually is way more
influential and successful as yes like
City theorist than he was as a particle
theorem that's right and again sometimes
so sometimes they'll have these kind of
happy endings with hindsight so it
didn't feel like an easy transition at
the time I'm sure an example that I that
I find really fascinating it's close to
my own heart and hopefully to yours is
the emergence of this field called
particle cosmology yeah which is an
amazing wonderful exciting super
terrific field I say that cuz I love it
I'm working it must be true but that
really was in that that was a kind of
unintended by-product again most of the
United States at the time of this kind
of just huge reversal of fortunes in the
physics field particle physics was hit
harder than any other subfield in the
early 70s again funding was cut by 50%
in a short window much like what
happened again in the 90s and so you see
this kind of intellectual migration
first thing that happens as many people
leave grad school can't get a job that's
one kind of effect it's just grinding
double-digit unemployment rates for PhD
scientists in the 70s and again in the
90s that's that's not good pots on
effective policy we had a physics
colloquium at Harvard when I was a grad
student there how to get a job on Wall
Street yep yep yep that's right that's
right and so when I was in grad school
two years after the vote to kill the SSC
I think it's the case that every PhD in
high-energy physics went into went to
Wall Street or kind of financial
consulting every single one of them that
that's another story that leads to a
different kind of bubble that burst as
we now again know in hindsight that
leads to yeah helps to fuel the dot-com
bubble and collateralized debt
obligations and all this fancy
derivative stuff on Wall Street but in
the in the 70s the first effect is an
out wave of people just leaving the
field a secondary effect is that twice
as many people leave particle physics as
enter it in an error
even the ones who stay in science who
stay in physics in particular the go to
these kind of neighboring or core hybrid
areas and it's not just by chance
there's a blue-ribbon panel that's
that's brought together by the National
Academy Sciences saying what happened in
this crisis and how do we prepare for
the next time in this twenty five
hundred page you know expert report on
what happened to physics I think was
actually called physics in crisis maybe
it's physics in transition but I think
it's crisis the the committee says the
particle theorists like you would me
part of the leaders were hit hardest
when the bad times came because we were
most narrowly trained they're saying
this about the early 70s that they had
become so hyper attuned to a certain
kind of question not being broadly
trained in the committee's view at least
and that's why that group suffered even
worse than any other field that also was
going under undergoing real strain so
they say we have to change how we train
high-energy theorists most of all they
have to be exposed to the broad areas of
physics different kinds of requirements
on coursework in general exams this is
when you start seeing a new wave of
attention curricular competi Gaja chol
eventually in funding to areas like
gravitation and cosmology and
astrophysics so it's not so surprisingly
by the middle to late 1970s after a new
wave of students have come in dreaming
of particle physics studying particle
theory but now also formally studying
general relativity and cosmology and
astrophysics new text books opinion
being written every year to supply the
need that they start asking questions at
this so the interface between
high-energy theory and cosmology a field
called particle cosmology is really kind
of amplified it's not created from
scratch but it really gets its
institutional foothold in it as a kind
of unintended consequence of this really
kind of macro scale shift in funding
priorities and and geopolitics a little
bit of making lemonade out of the lemons
that we're that's right that's right and
and from that we get you know now you
and I can tick off our favorite
successes but we get a whole kind of
amazing set of ideas about where our
universe came from where it might be
going what are the constituents have
mattered how we test them there's a
whole set of questions that people
weren't even posing right and so the
just the legitimacy of asking these
questions appears that's right even as
we don't yet know the final answers to
any of them
you and I know but I'm keeping that for
a future exact yeah stay tuned and a lot
of what is uh now that we're in the in
the present era in the discussion you
know there's this whole new thing of
asking for money from entities other
than the government that's right asking
for private money and if rubbing
shoulders with the government and their
secrecy and and warlike predilections
was problematic asking for money from
private individuals is problematic for a
whole new sets the reason it certainly
is and so there's a middle middle bezel
we know here I don't you know what I
might see with with with greater
seriousness than we should have known
earlier now it's week inescapable that
that's certainly right and is leading to
I mean overdue a real moment of real
soul-searching and I use that I mean I
really think it's soul-searching here on
campus is not going to go away soon it's
it's a real serious concern legitimate
concern but but there's a middle path as
well where it's not just individuals who
as we know can be sort of remarkably
problematic but but also and also to be
fair remarkably generous and helpful
I know that that's certainly true
spectrum it's the spectrum it's it's the
full range or it's not the full range
it's the range of human foibles among
very rich individuals so it's not the
full range of humanity as most of us
aren't that wealthy but it's it's the
range of the kind of human you know
complexities that's right and in between
there's a kind of buffer zone now which
i think is more substantial in terms of
both supporting numbers of researchers
and just the flow of dollars which are
private foundations or philanthropies
and again there's a kind of irony or
surprise here so a growing proportion of
research in our own field in many
neighboring fields is supported by
private dollars and that often means now
foundation money in addition to federal
sources National Science Foundation or
other agencies
the irony is that's in some sense a
return to what had been a model in the
United States in the 30s 1920s and 30s
or in Italy in the 17th century we're
all Galileo's now we're all seeking our
de Medici
but unlike seeking an individual you
know Cosimo de Medici ii who might have
been quirky we're now seeking in some
sense you know the foundation based on
de Medicis you know tax haven for his
family or whatever it might be
we're seeking it from a slightly more
institutionalized slightly more stay
structure of private money then the
foibles of of an individual and again
something I've looked at historically in
in in the 70s was again a turn to
private donors in the face of this of
this interruption of federal cash and
there it was often the instances I
looked at it was often quirky
individuals who were often extremely
generous and well well-intentioned to
you by many measures but it was also not
sturdy their personal situations could
change actually yeah their money they
could die and the family could disagree
on how to spend it more if it wasn't
such an endowed gift it was a it was a
recurring gift but not permanent and the
amount of money was often just frankly
not nearly the same the actual dollar
flow was not the same and so we have
that now of course sometimes with just
horrible effects not always sometimes
with wonderful effects but there's a
sort of slightly more institutionalized
range of the of the foundation which has
often uses something like peer review
often has a kind of buffer between the
wishes or aspirations of the donor and
the researchers so there's not that you
know people who get money from the Ford
Foundation have to improve you know
pintos right there's a way working out
something like an intellectual autonomy
or at least something approaching that
which is much harder work out with an
individual getting your writing you a
check
yeah and it can n agree more money can
it could be a little more stable I mean
I have very mixed feelings about the
whole thing I mean someone like Jim
Simon yeah the founder of Renaissance
Technologies one of the world's most
successful electronic trading firms
right has done an enormous amount for
science and you know enormous credit to
him not only funding scientists but also
publications like quanta that's right a
magazine you know it's probably the best
science magazine terrific existent right
now but they're you know they're
individuals and they're their primary
allegiance is not to the greater good
they have their quirky individual things
you know there's the Templeton
Foundation right John Templeton was sort
of the British Warren Buffett but he
also really wanted to reconcile science
and religion that rubbed some people the
wrong way
so there's choices that people make and
there's a lot the soul-searching is
gonna have to keep going on for a long
time when big institutions like our
universities decide you know when is it
worth the money where should we hand
things over and it's not just science
right the Koch brothers give money yeah
yeah economics and that's cool yeah
absolutely know that that's right and so
in some sense it's an we have our
generation has to face this it's not
actually a brand new challenge it is a
kind of in some ways returned it would
have been taken for granted you know
less than 100 years ago just in the
United States let alone in other times
in places you know MIT itself has gone
through these waves just looking just
you know kind of parochial II in my own
backyard we're now basically 100 years
past what was called the technology plan
here at MIT the tech plan which was
first introduced in in 1919
we had MIT had a president Richard
Maclaurin he was a math mad at Cambridge
trained mathematical physicist never he
had no practical knowledge me was a
university president for us here at MIT
and coming out of his first world war mi
t--'s you know finances were a mess and
he said we bet we need cash right
research and teaching is expensive so he
says we will actively cultivate
relationships with local industries a
school of technology after all and there
were lots of Boston area and
manufacturing firms and so the idea that
kind of makes sense sure a
public-private partnerships or higher
education with local industries sure but
you know a generation in fifteen years
later many many faculty on campus
including many engineers who've been
very involved with that project had a
kind of reassessment maybe more 10 10 12
years later and they said you know there
we gone too far that the faculty it was
later determined had given away too much
kind of direction of research too many
restrictions on who could publish what
you know who was calling the shots of
what would be studied and who could know
and there was we have to we have to
change we had to insert more buffers for
a kind of space for academic exploration
is not so closely tied to the whims of
generous nearby partners like in this
case private industry so that's so
that's roughly a hundred years ago
roughly 50 years ago we had another
moment of real reckoning here
MIT it's amazing just for you to say
that it's 100 years ago because it could
have been yesterday it could if some of
it feels very very current that's right
so so roughly 50 years ago in 1968 69 at
MIT and indeed in many other campuses
across the u.s. we had a different sort
of reckoning faculty and students and
staff and community members more broadly
what's the role why is the Pentagon
paying for such a high proportion of the
research on campus width again what seem
like inappropriate conditions or
restrictions and I mean like marches in
the street there are photographs in the
archives of you know local Cambridge
police with their billy clubs in their
riot gear clubbing you know protestors
in some protesters taking swings it was
really it was a real fight we're
marching down to or to demand the the
divestiture of MIT from certain kind of
defense oriented laboratories and demand
other kinds of changes in in in in
academic governance and who gets to to
say what who's gonna do what project and
who can share it so we have these sort
of moments you know a hundred years
roughly a hundred years ago it looked
like private monies the way to go
including in particular kind of
industrial money fifty years ago up
until 50 years ago it was simply beyond
question of course it's federal money
that's now the clean money so it seemed
until that seemed really really not so
clean in the midst of Vietnam war and
these other very serious concerns and so
we have these kind of pendulum swings
between whose money's is seemed sort of
obviously the way to go a kind of money
and we haven't found you know we haven't
threaded that needle yet not not
successfully and one of the extra issues
with private money is sometimes that
it's the rich get richer in kind of a
fact like they want to give money to the
sexiest most glamorous subfields or
whatever right researchers or
universities yep yeah version of that
too where even if we don't think about
you know very very wealthy individuals
it comes up now in in sort of crowd
funding for science to I I can ask about
this a fair amount by white journalists
who are writing about kind of
Kickstarter like campaigns for or
patreon type campaigns for science no
one had it's like wow what a what a
lovely idea I mean it appeals to me it
gets it means that some large number of
you know ordinary people are excited
about science so excited a lot you put
some of their own cash behind it that
who could not love that my way we have
very generous patreon supporters for the
mindscape podcast I love that thank
good--give or through patreon to me to
individual you know artists and creators
no it's not to knock the platform but
but as applied to kind of university
based scientific autocracy how could
possibly fill that role substantial on
the one hand the the volume I think
we're not gonna build an SSC with that
for barriers or other large things but
also how much of that's gonna be driven
by kind of you know the quirks of social
media fandom
who you know the the the best slickest
you know YouTube promotional video right
might attract more clicks more likes
we don't have peer review with all the
frustrations and flaws of period there's
at least a process there's at least
something like a procedure to try to
rationally allocate funds not perfect
right but it's at least a structure
crowdfunding's like hey that looks cool
click and so I have other concerns about
about other ways to engage you know
let's say private sources funding even
with again what I would think would be
wonderful intentions that's not gonna
get us you know that's not gonna bring
it to the promised land either no well
okay good so just to wind up then yeah
what will bring us to the problem how
these times should we be thinking yeah
sort of medium term thinkers here
I maybe it's it's just a mushy a kind of
milquetoast answer but I think we have
to have some combination like how could
we not and I think that not only for
let's say political reasons a kind of
drawing from many kinds of sources and
therefore many kinds of motivations but
I think you know physics has suffered
more than once in recent years in sort
of in living memory from being hooked on
a kind of monoculture on a single kind
of source because that source won't last
you know to infinity it might last over
decades sometimes it'll last much
shorter but it certainly doesn't it you
know a single single
you know element in the portfolio is not
the way to go so with something like
with our eyes open to buffers
peer-review academic freedom freedom to
publish with those kinds of controls or
or conditions really laid out in advance
then I think we can hopefully move nudge
toward a model that has federal input
maybe state and local governmental
inputs some kinds of found
and supports some kinds of private
private industrial support maybe some
some you know carefully vetted
individual generous donors as well and
maybe that's the way to fill out us in a
sustainable program and we might not get
to build the next SSC that way but we
hopefully could train a lot of really
smart students in the mean time well and
the other thing I think you are gonna
agree with me on this one so we're all
preaching to the converted here yeah but
physics the rest of science the rest of
academia could do a little better job of
making their case broadly for the
importance of what they do I think
that's exactly right and the importance
can include things like really important
contributions to the economy think about
think about the you know the electron at
the consumer electronics market where
would that be without basic research in
a host of fields physics chemistry many
fields of engineering so to
curiosity-driven research that has led
to what we now take for granted every
day so so clearly somebody will be
spin-offs applications will you know
kind of better living through chemistry
if that phrase weren't so so difficult
to say with a straight face but it also
should be something about what makes us
you know curious people what what what's
part of our human you know kind of quest
to know who we are where we are and
what's coming and I think that needn't
be tied to it to a short-term goal and
there has to be space there has to be
some balance some space to say we need
really open-ended curiosity we need
people support that even if it won't
make us better widgets Neela Indyk in
the next quarter you're singing my song
I got that's the perfect place to end
thanks you David Kiser thanks so much
we'll be on the podcast it was a real
pleasure thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]